hi my name is Lisa and I am the
president of the salsa club or the
speech of linguistic Students
Association essentially where our group
of speech Sciences and linguistics
students and our club tries to combine
these students together to have social
events and peer tutoring events and
various events to combine students and
professors together to form meaningful
relationships I really wanted to become
a member of salsa because I love the
community atmosphere of the club and I
wanted to meet other people who had
similar interests as me I want it to
become a member because I felt like
salsa was a great way to get to know
students in my faculty as well as the
professors in my back would see I
thought it was a great bridge between
the two and I was looking for
opportunities kind of in my field of
study and looking for ways to further my
academics I wanted to become a member of
salsa to get to know people within my
field to get to know people in classes
and stuff and also just to stay in the
loop about events that were happening
within the linguistics faculty try to
make some new friends
so I wanted to be a member of salsa
because I wanted to be involved in the
linked department as well as meet people
who share the same passions I think I
agree and I also want to have to that
he's like I don't know like it's a
really good way of getting to know more
people as she said I'm like the
opportunities that we have out there
like it's much better like in that way
to reach out to people and stuff like
that my favorite moment in linguistics
would have to be during 300 I was
learning about movement and movement of
kind of like particles and movement of
units as a ward unit and how that like
takes place so naturally inside of our
head
and I was just like oh my god I'm so
much smarter than I thought my favorite
moment in linguistics is um wine and
cheese night because I was an amazing
opportunity for students and faculty to
connect with each other as well as to
celebrate the end of term uh treatments
it's hard to boil it down to one single
moment like the whole experience of even
thing University itself it's just it's
so wild and it's nice to have like a
place where you kind of can contain all
that and have all the people that are in
the same boat as you um one of my
favorite moments and linguistics would
have to be I took a class in third year
called 2314 and we got to make a clay
model of the tongue and I thought it was
really interesting how we joined a
creative aspect into linguistics and
were able to kind of contextualize what
a time looks like and it was just fun to
be able to do a lot of my peers which is
welcoming salsa
[Music]
[Music]
you